we are over there trying to help them
how by starving them by killing them my
brother is over there trying to give
them a chance at freedom if you believe
that I seriously feel sorry for you
okay okay let's open this up what are
the rest of you think what are the
reasons behind terrorism political
injustice and resistance to occupation
is someone else a chance okay paddy I'm
sorry what what was that
she's rebellious she's a teenager who
wants to do what she wants to do she's
very political and very Pro Palestine
and let's every white bread kid know in
her class and she's really smart she's
got a good head on her shoulders I think
she's gonna go places but she's you know
about 16 and in high school when I was
that age when I was that age three years
ago huh I was I was a lot like that you
know experimenting with drugs and guys
and doing anything my parents told me
not to so she's smart but she just she
wants to feel everything very strongly
you know so that's why she's she really
pushes like the limit with her parents
so she couldn't she has strong emotions
and she doesn't know how to handle them
well I'm middle east for myself and the
character was very much when I was like
three years ago so I like playing myself
I guess as much as possible and I really
connected to Cherie and I really like um
you know she was really politically
active I guess when she was younger and
I think the way she's going about
sending this message is in a very
graceful way again as I said about not
being forceful and and she has such a
gift and I was just happy to be a part
of you know something she was involved
in she's a great director with with
actor she really connects with you and
she doesn't get nervous or panicked
under the pressure and this is really
her child and you know I've worked with
some directors they just everything is
so tense because everything has to be
perfect you know and she's just very
relaxed about it and she knows we're
gonna get it done and she appreciates
actors like opinions you know if I have
an idea at first see and she's like
willing to listen to it and even you
it and she's very you know trusting cuz
you know I've been working for a while
but she's very trusting like she's like
this take do whatever you wanted to do
it and I really like that so that's why
when she actually comes with me with the
direction I listen to every word you
know